de khadr vive con su familia en una
vivienda en riesgo de colapso el mes
pasado alcanzaron a recordar la escalera
para que no se hunda pero pasan las
noches en vela vuelven así vivimos
gracias a unos alemanes que vinieron y
nos pusieron estos andamios hemos podido
quedarnos pero hemos mandado a los niños
a casa de mi suegra no es seguro susan
otra vecina muestra la grieta en la
pared de su dormitorio que me queda
verse más puedo acceder al edificio
mira este es por fuera le hemos mandado
el vídeo a la municipalidad pero no
hemos recibido ninguna respuesta tenemos
mucho miedo el vernáculo ahora hill del
lamentablemente cada vez es más
frecuente este tipo de tragedias las
autoridades locales han reconocido que
hay más de 4.000 edificios en peligro de
colapso aquí en trípoli y
responsabilizan al gobierno central de
no haber tomado acción pero con un
estado en bancarrota
difícilmente el gobierno puede hacer
algo más que lamentar la próxima
tragedia durante años se ha permitido la
construcción según explica el arquitecto
base saudí el problema es que muchos de
los edificios abandonados durante la
guerra civil fueron ocupados por
familias pobres que han construido
legalmente encima se convierte en una
bomba de reducir a samborondón no
podemos culpar a la gente sin recursos
porque quiera tener una casa si el
gobierno hubiera puesto medidas
evitarían muchas tragedias
para halle de su familia fue demasiado
tarde el 26 de junio el edificio en el
que vivían se derrumbó su vieja y humana
acabó enterrada bajo los escombros rimas
tu esposa tiene ahora problemas de
movilidad viven en casa de su hermana
pero no hay día en el que no se lamente
por no haber podido proteger la vida
diciendo siento rabia dolor no es justo
y humana murió porque el estado no
proporciona viviendas adecuadas a los
tripolitanos
la foto de semana cuelga junto al
edificio derrumbado como recordatorio
regresar al lugar de la tragedia no le
es fácil en medio de los escombros
hallett desde la resignación se pregunta
quién será el próximo